it's actually quite straightforward to
make your apps content provider
available to third-party apps the key is
to modify the export flag in the
manifest entry here to true as simple as
that any app that knows the content URI
can use the content resolver to access
it the same way that you do now
depending on the sensitivity of your
data you may want to protect it by
requiring specific permissions to read
or write to the database so if you want
to you can effectively limit access only
to other apps you've created or to
third-party apps which know that
permissions and users agree to then you
just need to publish this contract to
interact with the content provider
specifically the URI
and column names and you've created a
simple API for all of your data and as
simple as that you've created a new API
just for your data this is exactly the
same approach used by many of the native
content providers including the contacts
database media store calendar and call
log